the new oil is ideas It's All Digital
all the new fortunes are being created
in idea space in fact if you're starting
out today as a young ambitious person
you don't learn real estate you don't
learn coal and oil mining you don't go
into extraction of physical resources to
create wealth you go into idea space you
go into programming books movies blogs
and podcasts and building robots which
are mostly intellectual property
underneath
I would focus on the content creator
side of things because I believe that's
where the puck is going that's a much
more important shift in how we all
consume information content and are
entertained
I really tend to believe as you've
probably gotten a sense of sort of
patterns and probabilities
and if you said to meth
probabilistically answer where where are
we going in apps and social experiences
what I would say is Lex
we spent the first decade building
platforms and getting them to scale
and if you want to think about it again
back to sort of this poker analogy
others mistakes minus your mistakes is
the value well the value that was
captured was trillions of dollars
essentially to Apple and to Google
and they did that by basically
um attracting billions of monthly active
users to their platform
then this next way were the apps
Facebook qq10 Tick Tock Twitter Snapchat
that whole panoply of apps
and interestingly they were in many ways
an atomized version of the platforms
right they sat on top of them they were
an ecosystem participant
but the value they created was the same
trillions of dollars of Enterprise Value
billions of monthly active users well
there's an interesting phenomenon that's
kind of hiding in plain sight
which is that the next most obvious
Atomic unit
are content creators now let me give you
two examples Lex Friedman this random
crazy guy uh Mr Beast you know Jimmy
Donaldson just the two of you alone add
it up okay and you guys are going to
approach in the next five years a
billion people the only thing that you
guys haven't figured out yet is how to
capture trillions of dollars of value
now maybe you don't want to and maybe
that's not your State admission right
right but let's just look at Mr Beast
alone because he is trying to do exactly
that probably yeah and I think Jimmy is
going to build an enormous business but
if you take Jimmy and all of the other
content creators right
you guys are atomizing
what the apps have done
you're providing your own curated news
feeds you're providing your own curated
communities you're allowed you let
people move in and out of these things
in a very lightweight way and value is
accruing to you so the honest answer to
your question is I would focus on the
content creator side of things because I
believe that's where the puck is going
that's a much more important shift in
how we all consume information content
and are entertained it's through Brands
like you individual people that we can
humanize and understand are the filter
like we get into this model of I must
work for other people work my way up the
ladder uh I must like do what that
person is doing to make money but really
today in society you get rewarded for
Creative work for creating something
brand new that Society didn't even know
yet that it wanted it doesn't know how
to get other than through you so the
most powerful money makers are actually
individual brands people like yourself
or Elon or Kanye or Oprah or Trump right
these are individual Brands eponymous
name brands who themselves are leveraged
like you're leveraged you have podcast
media going out to everybody that's
leveraged the podcast work for you when
you sleep they have knowledge that
nobody else has which is your knowledge
is the knowledge of being Joe Rogan I
mean who else is a UFC fighter and a
commentator and a podcaster and a
comedian and you know interested in all
these things and knows all these people
can't replace you so we have to pay you
what you're worth and it was I never
fought in the UFC though oh you didn't
okay sorry
um or you know whatever you're you're
involved in that whole scene you just
have a unique set of skill sets so
because of this unique what I call
specific knowledge because of the
accountability that you have with your
name because the leverage that you have
through your media you're a money making
machine you're like I'm sure at this
point I could make you start over
tomorrow wipe out your bank account
you'd be rich again in no time because
you have all the skill sets so once
people have those skill sets and the
beauty is the way you've done it is you
don't have any competition there's no
substitution if Joe Rogan were to
disappear off the air tomorrow it's not
like random podcaster number 12 would
step in and fill that thing no it's it's
just gone so the way to get out of that
competition trap is actually to be
authentic the way to retire is actually
to find the thing that you know how to
do better than anybody and you know how
to do that better anyway because you
love to do it no one can compete with
you if you love to do it be authentic
and then figure out how to map that to
what Society actually wants apply some
leverage put your name on it so you take
the risks but you gain the rewards have
ownership and equity in what you do and
then just crank it out then new oil is
ideas It's All Digital all the new
fortunes are being created in idea space
in fact if you're starting out today as
a young ambitious person you don't learn
real estate you don't learn coal and oil
mining you don't go into extraction of
physical resources to create wealth you
go into idea space you go into
programming books movies blogs and
podcasts and building robots which are
mostly intellectual property underneath
so even as a human civilization we're
moving away from Conquest to physical
resources and moving much more into
trading of ideas
I think four or five years from now
there's gonna be a lot of articles about
creators who are you know you will there
will be billionaire creators right a
handful of them you know yeah you'll
just start seeing it more and more and
more the direct to Consumer with your
influence especially with the data
Darkness thing that's going on with like
you can't track right yeah it used to be
really easy to just easy to find
audiences it's not as easy to find it if
you don't have it can you explain that
the date of Darkness basically yeah you
could track people you know you could
Facebook collected everything so if you
want if you had a widget and you wanted
to find people who would want to buy
that widget it was pretty easy because
they give you all the data and they say
I love widgets and here's my birthday
and here are the other things I like
it's really easy to find those audience
now with the date of Darkness where you
can't be tracked and stuff and cookie
policy it's harder to find those people
and so I was always like I cannot
believe Brands pay me as much as they do
to do these Integrations you know before
I had my own business and now that I
have my own business I'm like those sobs
were ripping me off oh you know what I
mean it's like when you have your own
audience and your own company you can
pitch then it's like oh like yeah
I was making them more money than they
were paying me and they you know what I
mean and then and sometimes the other
thing with like well it didn't perform
as well as we wanted it's like no dude I
know that's not true now you know this
is the kind of Entrepreneurship or or
product Market fit flipped on its head
where you know previously someone would
create crunch labs they would say okay I
have these I want to teach kids how to
engineer now I need to go find an
audience for them but now it's the
inverse where it's hey I have this
massive audience interested in building
and Engineering let me build a company
around that premise which is which is I
think why we're heading towards
billionaire yeah creators I agree
what's the best thing to start doing on
YouTube whatever you love Whatever Gets
you excited gets you out of the bed in
the morning that's the type of videos
you should be making what are you
genuinely curious and passionate about I
mean
um people on YouTube get views for like
the strangest things you know what I
mean like I bet you if we like there's
someone who's making a living painting
bowling balls I don't know but like you
know there's this one board game I love
playing and I was you know watching a
tutorial watching some videos on it it's
like not even that popular of a board
game and the guy making the videos
um was like a school teacher and like in
one of the videos he mentioned how his
channel on just this simple board game
was doing so well that he was able to
like quit his job as a teacher and and
he went full time making videos about
this board game you know what I mean and
that's like that's one of those things
where like you know if he was being over
analytical people would be like don't
don't make videos on a board game who
cares about that board game but it's
what he loved and it's what he was
passionate about and so that pushed him
to grind and putting the effort and you
know he found an audience and some
yeah my answer is make videos on
whatever you love and you'll make it a
lot further it's the same thing like
like don't you know people say don't do
YouTube for money and the thing is it's
not like wanting money isn't gonna cause
you to fail but if that's your focus
it's like
um I mean set aside money related videos
like Graham Steven and or Stefan and all
them but it's just if that's your focus
you're not gonna put in as many hours
and you're not gonna obsess as much than
if it was something that you genuinely
did as a hobby and and loved creating
reflections
another perspective that I have found
very useful is from Alex ormosi he
argues that just like in the past
fortunes were made on oil today's
fortunes are made on attention since
anyone can build an audience thanks to
the infinite leverage of the internet
and you build an audience by being
authentic to yourself by doing what you
love and pursuing your genuine curiosity
and that will naturally bring you
authentic ideas which then you can
package in a digital format to then be
consumed by anyone on the internet who
enjoys your ideas and your work in my
opinion this is why Navarro account and
Alex hermosi have said that ideas and
attention are the new oil because once
you have an audience and the attention
it is relatively easy to monetize
through ads Revenue brand deals and
affiliate marketing or even create your
own business which could solve the most
common need of your audience and you
wouldn't have to spend a penny on
marketing on this YouTube channel in
particular the content is just slides
that I create from the Nugget that I
pick to help people understand more
easily these ideas a 65 percent of the
general population are visual Learners
including me and I make all of my slides
and also my thumbnails on canva which is
an awesome tool because you can
essentially leverage over the designs of
millions of Independent Artists who
Supply their creative work to the
platform and if you want to learn how I
personally make my thumbnails on canva
you can take my free course that I just
created I will show you from scratch how
to create a thumbnail I will also show
you all the tricks that I have learned
over two years of making videos on
YouTube and also you will learn how to
use canvas creative leverage in general
to make cool slides on YouTube so if you
want to check out my course just go to
the first link in the video description
it is free of charge and I will only
earn a commission if you pay for canva
pro which is the premium version of
kamba and with my link you can get a 30
day free trial but if you don't want to
try the premium version that's also
perfectly fine because in the course I
will show you some workarounds whenever
I'm using exclusive kamba raw features
so I hope to see you in the course